اسمحوا لي أن أسألك عن سياسة دونالد ترامب في
الشرق الأوسط التي ذهب إلى المملكة
العربية السعودية واجتمع مع دول الخليج
ويبدو أن التركيز في ذلك الاجتماع
كان محاولة حشد نوع من
التحالف المناهض لإيران الذي
أراد السعوديون القيام به بشكل خاص.  فيما
يتعلق بالحرب في اليمن ولكن أيضًا
بشكل عام عزل قطر التي يُنظر إليها على
أنها صديقة للغاية لإيران ، ما هو
رد فعلك على ذلك جيدًا ، كل ما يمكنني قوله
هو أنها سياسة في غير محلها ومضللة
نعرف من أين يأتي الإرهابيون.
أولئك الذين هاجموا
مركز التجارة العالمي ، ومواطني الدول الكلبة
في المنطقة ، يمكنني أن أقول لكم أن
أياً منهم لم يأت من إيران ، ولم يأتِ أي من
الأشخاص الذين شاركوا في أعمال إرهابية
منذ عام 2001 من إيران ، ومعظمهم
جاء من حلفاء الولايات المتحدة
، وأعتقد أن  الأيديولوجية التي
ينشرها للأسف جيراننا
في المملكة العربية السعودية في جميع أنحاء العالم هي
المسؤولة عن كراهية التطرف
والتعصب الذي يجلب مثل هذه
الصفحة المظلمة من الناس.  الذين ليس لهم
علاقة بالإسلام في
منطقتنا وحتى خارج منطقتنا ، انظروا إلى داعش ،
انظروا إلى نوسترا ، انظروا إلى القاعدة ، انظروا إلى
المنظمات الإرهابية الأخرى ، كل
منهم ليس لديه أي
علاقة بإيران ، كلهم يتلقون ليس فق
أيديولوجيتهم ولكن مساعدتهم المالية
أسلحتهم من
الآخرين الذين يسمون أنفسهم حلفاء الولايات المتحدة